imagine if you're a three-time NBA
champion Finals MVP hall-of-famer you
playing the City of LA for the Lakers
what the limelight
spotlight everywhere you go everyone
knows who you are how does someone like
that deal with distractions
here's James Worthy in a second part of
his interview talking about distractions
as well as the importance of having a
mentor
distractions are going to come for sure
particularly when you put yourself in an
environment that is under the microscope
24/7 and in today's world with social
media and tweeting all the Instagram
stuff that's impossible because
everywhere you go whatever you do if you
go to a nightclub it's gonna be
somethings Papa sized so while you're
growing as a human being
and you have all the challenges that
every man and woman has in life whether
it's marriage whether it's business
whether it's just growing as an
individual whether you have fears and
anxiety that have been with you since
you were eight years old and you bring
them into your adult life all those
things aren't gonna go away
regardless if whether you're a janitor
or their school teacher or whether you
were professional athlete
they just manifest and so you deal with
it
just like you no politician would there
are obstacles and troubles that come
your way I know personally I've had
things that I've had to overcome but you
have to realize that you are a good
person and that you can't be repetitive
in your mistakes and you have to be
honest with yourself that's one of the
biggest things that this weapon is
looking at the mirror and realizing that
you just look human being and despite
all the distractions you don't get a
pass because you're a certain vibe you
have to identify your distractions
interests and try to eliminate them
because they're going to come whether
it's new job new contracts divorce
girlfriend women
alcohol all the things that we
experience as human beings are going to
be there their heightened when you get
money and when you're in a environment
of unrealistic fantasies and that's
where you need to have a good family
structure and a good mentor and you have
to listen to people I was fortunate
enough to have Jerry West coach Smith
and my parents were excellent but you
have to find somebody that's been there
it's someone you can trust because
you're gonna have you know you're going
to come to an impasse sometime in life
and it's just a matter are you willing
to to listen or are you going to try to
be that more more and there are good
mentors anybody out there and say they
can't find a mentor they're not telling
the truth because mentor is telling the
truth and it hurts and when it hurts and
when you it gets under your skin a
little bit you found them in too